in your mathematical careers you might
encounter people who say it is wrong to
say that I is equal to the principal
square root of negative one and if you
ask them why is this wrong they'll show
up with this this kind of line of logic
that actually seems pretty reasonable
they will tell you that okay well let's
just start with negative one we know
from definition that negative one is
equal to I times I everything seems
pretty straightforward right now and
then they'll say well look if you take
this if you assume this part right here
then we can replace each of these eyes
with the square root of negative one and
they'd be right so then this would be
the same thing as the square root of
negative 1 times the square root of
negative 1 and then they would tell you
that hey look just from straight up
properties of the principal square root
function they'll tell you that the
square root of a times B is the same
thing as the principal square root of a
times the principal square root of B and
so if you have the principal square root
of a times the principal square root of
B that's the same thing as the square
root of a times B so based on this
property of the radical of the of the
principal root they'll say that this
over here is the same thing as the
square root of negative 1 times negative
1 of negative 1 times negative 1 if I
have the principal root of the product
of two things that's the same thing as
the product of each of their principal
roots I'm doing this in the other order
here here I had the principal root of
the products over here I have this on
the right and then from that we all know
that negative 1 times negative 1 is 1 so
this should be equal to the principal
square root of 1 and then the principal
square root of 1 remember this this
radical needs principal square root
positive square root that is just going
to be positive 1 and they'll say this is
wrong clearly clearly negative 1 and
positive 1 are not the same thing and
they'll argue therefore you can't make
this substitution that I that we did in
this step and what you should then point
out is that this was not the incorrect
step that it is true negative 1 is not
equal to 1 but the faulty line of
reasoning here
was in using this property was in using
this property when both a and B are
negative if both a and B are negative
this will never be true so a a and B
both cannot cannot be both cannot be
negative
in fact normally when this property is
given sometimes it's given a little bit
in the footnotes or you might not even
notice it because it's not relevant when
you're learning it the first time but
they'll usually give a little bit of a
constraint there they'll usually say for
for a a and B greater than or equal to
zero so that's where they list this
property this is true for a and B
greater than equals zero and in
particular its false if both a and B are
both if they are both negative now I've
said that I've just spent the last three
minutes saying that people who tell you
that this is wrong are wrong but with
that said I do I will say that you have
to be a little bit careful about it you
have to be a little bit careful about it
when we take traditional principle
square roots so when you take this
principal square root of four we know
that this is positive two that four
actually has two square roots there's
negative two is also a square root of
also is a square root square root of
four if you have negative two times
negative two it's also equal to four
this radical symbol here means principal
square root or when we're just dealing
with real numbers not imaginary non
complex numbers you can really view it
as the positive square root this has two
square roots positive and negative two
if you have this radical symbol right
here principal square roots it means the
positive square root of two so when you
when you start thinking about taking
square roots of negative numbers or even
in the future we'll do imaginary numbers
and complex numbers and all the rest you
have to expand the definition of what
this radical means so when you are
taking the square root of when you are
taking the square root really of any of
any negative number you're really saying
that this is no longer the traditional
principal square root function you're
now talking that this is the principal
complex square root function or this is
now defined for complex inputs
or the domain and can also generate
imaginary or complex outputs or I guess
you could call that you could call that
the range and if you assume that then
really straight from straight from this
you get that negative the square root of
negative x is going to be equal to I
times the square root of x and this is
only and I'm going to make this clear
because I just told you that this will
be false of both a and B or negative so
this is only true so we can apply this
we can apply we can apply this we can
apply when when X when X is greater than
or equal to zero so if X is greater than
or equal to zero the negative X is
clearly a negative number or I guess it
could also be zero it's a negative
number and then we can apply this right
over here if X was less than zero then
we would be doing all of this nonsense
up here and we would start to get
nonsensical answers and if you look at
it this way and you say hey look I can
be the square root of negative one if
we're taking the if it's the principle
branch of the complex square root
function then you could rewrite this
right over here as the square root of
negative one x times the square root
times the square root of x and so really
the real fault in this logic why what
when people say hey one negative one
can't be equal to one the real fault is
using this property is using this
property when both a and B where both of
these are negative numbers that will
come up with something that is
unambiguously false if you expand your
definition of the complex expand your
definition of the principal root to
include negative numbers in the domain
and including and to include imaginary
numbers then you can do this you can say
the square root of negative x is
negative the square root of negative 1
times the or you say that the principal
square root of negative x I should be
particularly my words is the same thing
as the principal square root of negative
1 times the principal square root of x
when X is greater than or equal to 0 and
I don't want to confuse you if X is
greater than or equal to 0 this is
clearly this negative X then is clearly
a
or I guess you say a non positive number